Oi boa tarde a todos eu gostava de dizer
em primeiro lugar que eu sou professor é
por Primeira opção não houve aqui em um
engano não foi por mera casualidade ou
talvez um erro na candidatura na
submissão da candidatura ao ensino
superior não esse em uma dessas
situações eu estou nesta profissão no
mundo da educação porque de facto é que
ele mundo que me faxina e aquele mundo
que eu quero dedicar a minha vida a ele
até estar os meus olhos e portanto desde
que me lembro que eu respiro educação
desde que me lembro que gosto de deste
ambiente da escola e de passar os meus
dias neste espaço estão agradáveis se
vocês se aperceberem
e este esta imagem que aqui temos mostra
a escola que nós temos são
os materiais muito muito atuais vemos aí
mesas cadeiras muito modernas mas
repararmos bem o estilo com que está a
ser realizada a aula o modelo conquistar
a ser dinamizado aula é um modelo que se
calhar Todos Nós aprendemos um modelo
muito muito clássico muito tradicional
em que vemos a professora à frente a
comandar a direcionar EA transmitir
todos os conhecimentos um modelo baseado
no ensino e temos alunos passivos a
receberem a informação que a professora
da Esta é a escola que maioritariamente
ainda temos podemos dizer que ainda é
escola de massas é uma escola que facto
dá acesso a todos mas não dá sucesso
para todos os alunos e então
e nós temos que pensar que os alunos não
são todos iguais e portanto a não serem
todos iguais nós temos que pensar em
estratégias diferenciadoras para que
todos alcancem o sucesso e pensar em
métodos diferentes materiais recursos
diferenciar tudo aquilo que pudermos
para tornar a qualidade de ensino e
aprendizagem melhor é uma mais-valia no
mundo da educação e nós estamos a falar
em facilitismos quando queremos criar
não só o acesso mas o sucesso para todos
os nossos alunos e falo disto na escola
em que temos também não só em questão da
dos recursos que temos que diferenciar
para chegar a todos EA cada um Porque
nós não somos todos iguais falo disto
também na questão da avaliação da
questão da avaliação no âmbito da
classificação Queremos ser um
e cíveis com todos os alunos e
dificilmente nos diferenciamos técnicas
e instrumentos para recolher informação
na altura de classificar um aluno então
achamos que a escola acha que é muito
justo usar o teste o teste realmente é
um instrumento de medida mais mais justo
mais correto quando damos um mesmo
instrumento para todos e temos o que uma
diversidade de alunos a nossa frente e
eu olho para esta imagem e quando o
professor diz por favor façam a prova a
prova é subir ao cimo daquela árvore
chegar a Copa daquela árvore eu penso
coitado do peixinho que não tem asas
para voar nem tenho Patinhas para poder
trepar aquela árvore será isto um ensino
e uma aprendizagem de qualidade pergunto
eu será que está
Essa é a facilitar o ensino ou a
dificultar a aprendizagem Então qual
será a missão da Escola acho que aqui
uma grande contradição grande paradoxo
porque a escola do Século 21 deseja
formar alunos o mais completo possível
deseja que a sua formação seja
harmoniosa e deseja dar valor a um
conjunto complexo de conhecimentos
capacidades e atitudes que nós chamamos
de competências e é preciso estimular os
alunos para desenvolver o seu pensamento
crítico e criativo para desenvolver o
raciocínio EA resolução de problemas não
só na disciplina de matemática mas na
sua vida em geral é preciso desenvolver
o e saber trabalhar em equipe estou aqui
há a recorrer ao relacionamento
interpessoal é preciso
nós vamos trabalhar todos juntos é
preciso apreciar as ideias dos outros
por vezes é preciso digamos assim
criticar ideias forma construtiva e não
criticar pessoas é preciso aprender a
saber estar e a sabermos viver uns com
os outros é preciso dar tempo para se
desenvolver a sensibilidade estética e
artística artística e todos os outros
aspectos todas as outras áreas de
competência e que estão inscritas no
perfil dos alunos a saída da
escolaridade obrigatória que é um
documento estruturante que marca a vida
das escolas na atualidade e como é que
nós damos resposta a todos é todas estes
desafios temos que dar resposta a
resposta não é difícil se encontrar
sabendo que temos que preparar o melhor
possível os nossos alunos para as
exigências da sociedade atual e até
prepará-los para profissões que ainda
nem sequer foram criadas como é que
é só estamos à altura deste tão grande
desafio
Oi e a resposta já foi inventada a
resposta está na utilização de
metodologias ativas de
ensino-aprendizagem onde o aluno passa a
ser o centro da aprendizagem o foco da
atenção e onde passamos de deixe de
estar preocupados com o ensino para
valorizar a aprendizagem depois dentro
de destas inúmeras metodologias de
ensino-aprendizagem existe uma delas que
a aprendizagem cooperativa que é que é
com esta metodologia que eu tenho
trabalhado nos meus últimos 15 anos
tenho investigado dado aulas a formar
professores nesta área e por que esta
esta metodologia porque esta metodologia
tem potencial necessário para mudar
práticas pedagógicas no ambiente
estruturado apoiado e em contexto é uma
metodologia que valoriza todo o trabalho
feito aba
o construtivismo e que o trabalho entre
entre pares e os grupos cooperativos são
seu eixo fundamental estamos a falar de
uma de uma metodologia que valoriza
tanto as capacidades cognitivas
academicas como também as competências
sociais cooperativas e emocionais também
tudo aquilo que nos é pedido no perfil
dos alunos tanto estamos a falar de uma
metodologia que dá a resposta aquilo que
se pretende que os alunos desenvolvam
nas nossas escolas nos 12 anos de
escolaridade obrigatória e dentro da
aprendizagem cooperativa os grupos
heterogêneos trabalham de forma muito
organizada nós às vezes pensamos sais
são os meninos estão os meninos do 1º
ciclo do 2º ao 3º ciclo e do secundário
estão ali nos grupos heterogêneos a
trabalhar e nós temos só a ver não tem
nada a ver com isto trata-se de uma
é muito estruturada e que o professor
aos professores que a equipa trabalham
com esta metodologia depois de fazer a
informação tem que ter em conta em
primeiro lugar estas Cinco
características ou princípios que
sustentam esta metodologia que nasceu
nos anos 60 70 nos Estados Unidos da
América em uma delas tem ali prioridade
são todas imprescindíveis mas vou
começar por referir a interdependência
positiva que pode ser a nível de papéis
de recursos de objetivos de identidade
ela é o coração da aprendizagem
cooperativa em interação face-a-face é
também outra das características
essenciais nós professores não
conseguimos ver tudo nem chegar a todos
ao mesmo tempo e temos que estar
preocupados com a aprendizagem de todos
e de cada um e os alunos quando estão a
trabalhar nestes grupos heterogêneos a
percebem-se de pequenos grandes
pormenores que às vezes nós professores
não
bom detectar e portanto esta também é
uma característica fundamental para
poder trabalhar com os alunos em grupos
cooperativos relações interpessoais é
fundamental também aprender a trabalhar
em equipa a Atlas que nascem que tem
tendência natural para poder estar em
equipa e são líderes natos outros também
não a escola tem essa obrigação de
ensinar os alunos a saber trabalhar em
uns com os outros respeitarem uns aos
outros promover a escuta ativa e
perceberem que quando trabalhamos em
equipa tiramos muito maior proveito
todos juntos Como disse o orador também
esteve conosco anteriormente e vários
estudos também comprovam que os alunos
quando estudam a equipa e fazem
aprendizagens a equipa de tornam-se
depois muito mais competentes não só a
nível anível a nível coletivo mas também
o individual avaliação de grupo é outra
das características essenciais quando
trabalhamos com a aprendizagem
cooperativa o professor tem que dar
feedback em tempo útil aos seus alunos
os alunos autoavaliam seu trabalho é
troll avalia um mesmo trabalho que fazem
no seu pequeno grupo e no grande grupo
esté uma avaliação Inter Inter pares que
acontece no desenvolver das tarefas no
término dos Desafios e que tem que estar
presente o aluno tem que fazer aqui a
sua auto e hetero-avaliação e
auto-regulação também das suas
aprendizagens e por último mas não menos
importante a responsabilidade individual
o sucesso de um é o sucesso dos outros
esse nos apercebemos que alguns alunos
estão a trabalhar e outros estão a
sombra do trabalho de outros não estamos
a falar de aprendizagem cooperativa nem
do Trabalho em grupos heterogêneos por
outro
e como é que nós asseguramos este papel
parte participativo ativo na sociedade
na comunidade local dos nossos alunos
através
é através da distribuição de tarefas
dentro do grupo que cada elemento tem
funções muito específicas dentro do
grupo para que possa crescer e
desenvolver-se em diferentes domínios e
é muito interessante porque estes papéis
que os alunos assumem intencionalmente
são rotativos e isto para que para nós
percebermos e termos a certeza de que
todos os alunos a experiência um
diferentes competências e conseguem
crescer formativamente em vários
domínios depois quando já estão muito
familiarizados com a aprendizagem
cooperativa por vezes até acumulam
acumulam funções duas e três funções
para o mesmo aluno e acaba por ser um
desafio para além dos papéis e funções
que cada um assegura em cada tarefa em
cada projeto aprendizagem cooperativa e
também servida por um conjunto de
métodos
é aqui que as abordagens como queremos
chamar um as mais formais outras mais
informais temos métodos ou técnicas para
todos os níveis de escolaridade ou a
Kefir o mesmo desde o pré-escolar ao
ensino superior existem métodos mais
adequados para as ciências exatas outros
para as Ciências Sociais e ainda métodos
se adequam perfeitamente ao trabalho
Inter e transdisciplinar e que são
muitas vezes usados pelos professores
que utilizam esta metodologia através do
trabalho de projecto eu queria só
colocar aqui uma questão tem ideia de
quantos métodos ou técnicas existem
dentro desta metodologia da aprendizagem
cooperativa
se alguém que diga o número
e ninguém diz que
os 10 boa venda mais
há 50 está mais perto
e sem bingo acertou cerca de 100 métodos
de aprendizagem ao serviço da educação
eu gostava de vos dizer que desde 2016
fui convidada para organizar construir
um projeto todo ele sustentado na
aprendizagem cooperativa com recursos
Obviamente as tecnologias EA todas e a
tua é tudo o que está ao nosso ao nosso
dispor para promover a qualidade das
aprendizagens dos nossos alunos esse
projeto chama-se Coopera é um projeto de
intervenção pedagógica que promove a
qualidade das aprendizagens dos alunos e
o seu sucesso escolar nasceu aqui em
Vila Nova de Gaia no agrupamento com
cinco escolas agrupamento Escultor
Antônio Fernandes de Sá e desde então
este projecto tem-se vindo a a
disseminar não só por Vila Nova de Gaia
mas por outras escolas em diferentes
regiões do nosso país
O que é possível ver estamos a trabalhar
com 20 escolas 150 turmas 350
professores e cerca de três mil alunos
com quem trabalhamos em contexto de
Formação ou seja com acompanhamento
muito muito estruturado e com e com
assertividade Rigor e comprometimento da
nossa parte tem sido um trabalho muito
desafiante e que nos tem dado muito
muito muito além de alegria tem sido
muito recompensador ver a escola que
temos a mudar como qualquer outro
projeto os projetos tem que ser
monitorizados investimos nestas
variáveis que aqui estão e de facto os
alunos têm melhorado a sua crença de
autoeficácia as competências sociais a
motivação e o rendimento escolar os
professores também se percebem que há
uma melhoria no clima de sala de
e na estimativa do desempenho escolar e
na autoeficácia percebida na docência e
termina com este slide dizendo infinito
é o tema que que nos move aqui hoje
infinito além de limites e fronteiras
Então paixão pergunto eu os limites e as
fronteiras para termos Esta escola
bom obrigada
[Aplausos]